shannon is with me in Cedar Rapids Iowa
hi Shannon how are you I'm doing very
well how are you sir better than I
deserve what's up I just want to say
first of all it's an honor to talk to
you I've recently been introduced to
your products and tier services that you
offer and you are a rock star at our
house well bless your heart thank you
how can I help the reason I'm calling is
I just completed Financial Peace
University last week so that was that
was done and I'm grateful that I did it
the only issue that I have is that I am
all gung ho for this but I have a
husband who is very much the opposite
we were both signed up to take the class
and as soon as he found out that it was
biblically based he was out he didn't
want anything to do with it and I went
to the classes by myself with a friend
of mine and I would come home every
night you know rejuvenated and ready to
take on the debt and he just didn't feel
the same way I'm so sorry
that has to be no not not financial
stuff inside the financial stuff aside
the financial stuff aside the
relationship aspects of what you're
telling me are just heartbreaking
yes I mean you guys realize I just
really have a meltdown going on don't
you yeah and it's just one of those
things that he always has to be the
smartest person in the room and you know
his way is the best way and everything
and I'm teaching my children my daughter
actually took your daughter's class at
in a financial literacy class if she's
aware of you know the whole process and
how it works and she's gonna call about
it and I have a son who I'm trying to
teach the same principles of saving and
you know giving and things like that
but I'm afraid home mom and my husband
is a breadwinner and all of you all
married um seven years and he works in
the medical field so he he makes enough
money and there's no reason we should
have any consumer debt at all but we're
just kind of at an impasse right now as
to how we're going to tackle the debt
yeah well you're at an impasse and the
debt has nothing to do with it your
world views are colliding and
and there's a respect meltdown here
where you know he's the king of
everything and you're not your opinion
doesn't matter doesn't count your vote
doesn't count in this relationship and
it's stability and my suspicion is this
hasn't they've Ramsey another Financial
Peace University this has to do with
your relationship with you I agree a
hundred percent and so I mean it doesn't
have to do you know there's how do we
get your husband on board oh we don't
uncle until he decides he's going to be
on board with being your husband and and
he's not on board with that right now
he's just doing whatever the flip he
wants to do and the rest of you people
exist around him and so you know I think
you probably and I'm guessing he thinks
there's no issue with your marriage well
I do think there's an issue with your
marriage just based on what you're
telling me it's saddens me it breaks my
heart so I think the two of you need to
start seeing a marriage counselor I
doubt he will go but I think you're
going to need to go on because you're
you're trying to work around this
elephant that's in the middle of your
living room and the elephant is not
moving and you can't work around it you
know you can move the furniture you can
do everything there's still an elephant
in your room and you just you you guys
are going to have to deal with this and
it's not it's probably not going to be
pretty it's probably going to be very um
very stressful
um but you know I didn't do that and
Financial Peace University didn't do
that that was there before we came along
this just revealed again um that you
guys have a completely different way of
looking at the world and and that's not
just a biblical issue it's you know
biblical worldview it's it's you know
whether you have a vote of any kind in
this process and apparently you don't is
what you're telling me I'm so sorry it's
just heartbreaking honey but you need to
see a marriage counselor you see your
pastor and get a recommendation for a
good marriage counselor and hopefully
he'll go with you and hopefully you guys
can work through this I sure hope you
can hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content
and check out these other great clips
from the show
[Music]